kareem abdul-jabbar obviously one of the
great players of all time
four-time award-winning columnist and
writes regularly for publications
including The Hollywood Reporter The
Guardian and LA Times his new technology
surface service offers a direct custom
video messaging also check out economy
dot-com which helps pro athletes create
brand equity and expand their legacy
beyond sports to support themselves
after retirement Kareem joins us this
morning good morning Kareem how are you
I don't know if you saw this I hate to
bring it up to you now Wes Unseld passed
away I know that and I was trying to
tell people how unique Wes Unseld was
you know he missed out on the the TV era
but it felt like he was 6-7 about 250 or
260 yeah
sometimes you get lucky you could reach
over them and get a rebound but Wes was
was great it just he could keep you away
from a certain area and you know the
rebound could bounce off the floor and
he pick it up you know because you can
couldn't get to that position on the
court he would sit he learned how to use
his bulk and size to to give himself a
rebounding space and he was very
effective at yeah he was one of those
guys who defied logic he was like Paul
Silas they weren't great leapers but it
felt like they were getting every
rebound and he played on that great
bullets team with Elvin Hayes and Phil
Cheniere that won a title yeah I love
the op-ed in the LA Times obviously very
powerful but I've come to expect that
from you take take us back to late 60s I
think if we are we any better any
different now improved and handling you
know these situations well I think we've
been through the ups and downs we've
seen the progress and in the backsliding
that has occurred since the heyday of
the civil-rights you know I remember
when between my dream
senior year in high school young man
James Powell got killed on the streets
of New York riot by police officer and
arlynn broke out in about two or three
days of riots so this that that was 56
years ago so you know none of this is
new it's happened to many times before
and we have to do something to get to a
point where this is not where it doesn't
happen like it does it just seems to
just play into a really bad situation
every time so we've got to learn how to
deal with that but I wonder about
everybody's role in this because it
feels like if something happens we tend
to put this on the black community to
say hey this is on you when it it's
really on the white community to
understand this or how do we advance
this if you were going to speak to an
audience I would have to say that if you
when it's easy to dismiss somebody's
humanity and the fact that they are a
person with rights and expectations that
no one should mutually respect when that
goes out the window you know all of
these abuses are they just become
commonplace and you know we the whole
idea that a segment of society is
considered not worthy or not equal is
going to lead to what we have seen Appl
and you start to wonder about we've had
these great leaders like dr. King
or if Muhammad Ali was still a lot like
I wonder about just these individuals in
what they meant to history how would I
do you think dr. King would view what
happened in Minneapolis well he would
see it in conjunction with all the other
lynchings and murders of black people
that have happened prior to that it's
not an uncommon story it's too
commonplace that I think that's why we
that
don't do anything to change it because
we've accepted it for so long I also
worry though that we move on so quickly
Kareem when something happens and then
we're outraged and then this will go
away this will dissipate we've seen this
before
and then the next outrage will get
everybody excited for a little while and
then they'll forget about it because
we've accepted it for so long it's just
you know the way that the way that we do
business and we can't do it like that
anymore there has to be some type of
change and what it's all about I think
at this point is we have to find some
means to deal with bad cops
you know bad cops make it bad for good
cops they make it bad for citizens of
color poor people the bad cops are able
to just do what they want in those
situations so you know when we get to
the point where that's not a problem I
think we will have made a lot of
progress you were one of the more famous
teenagers in the United States when you
were playing at power Memorial did you
have any run-ins with the police of
course of course you know and I had a
gun pulled on me for being tall and dark
you know that was it really um yeah and
one time I one of my son's was bringing
one of my other sons home and the police
stopped him they wanted to know what
what he was doing driving around an
expensive car and they thought that that
was suspicious and jacked him up it
happens it just it's part of our culture
and it's part of how we see things and
we've got to change that I thought the
mayor of Atlanta had powerful words when
she just said you know this is like I
can't send my son out to do a piece so I
can't send you out I can't protect you
and I don't know how helpless that may
feel for you that you know you you worry
about your kids and you want to protect
them and you want them to have an idea
to conduct themselves so they won't be
in any any danger and for black kids
that's at the very iffy situation we're
talking to Kareem abdul-jabbar Muhammad
Ali died four years ago yesterday
remember the first tiny menu yes I do
yeah what was that I was just walking
down sunset and Muhammad Ali was out
there doing magic tricks for people I
was just walking by and two friends of
mine and we stopped in Washington for
about 10 or 15 minutes and then kept on
and then a couple of weeks later I went
to a party I was during my freshman year
at UCLA I went to a party and he was
there and I got to meet him and just
clicked this is a great guy
wait I don't know what stranger you
walking on sunset or ally doing magic
tricks on sunset it was 1966 for him
1966 I remember yeah what don't I know
about him oh that he was a really funny
guy he biked he was a practical joker
you know you like to pull jokes on
people and mystify them with some of his
magic abilities he tried magic tricks
for for a long time because he just
liked to make people go WOW but then he
could get into the ring and be so
violent like one of the chap late was
such a playful man yeah then you turn it
on and turn it off
you know we saw that with the Jordan
documentary Mike doesn't turn it on and
off it's always on yeah he was like he
was a really congenial guy I wonder
about his impact because I've maintained
I think Jackie Robinson is probably the
greatest athlete of all time because
baseball basketball football track and
field he became a hall-of-famer when
people didn't want him to
succeed what he went through to do that
and then there's Ali's place in history
I I don't know if you can categorize
that but trying to the impact of ollie
and I said this when he died Kareem four
years ago he's leaving a legacy of
athletes who are willing to step up now
I think because they saw who he was when
they saw all these testimonials these
tributes to Ali when he died that you
had LeBron and Chris Paul and Dwyane
Wade and guys who were willing to put
themselves out there that's a I mean
that's a powerful legacy that Ali left
yeah black athletes really for black
kids black athletes are the the
principal role models and black kids get
a lot of positive direction from from
back black athletes I know I did when
Jackie was playing for the Dodgers you
know I was serious doctor fan it he just
that that kind of charisma really has an
effect and he never let it boil over
though how do you think Jackie Robinson
compartmentalized this with everything
he's gone I mean I'm sure internally but
he sort of maintained his dignity yeah
it was so hard to do at that time
because people wanted to test it but you
know he had the right disposition and I
he was definitely equipped he was pretty
tough guy he a lot of those guys in the
majors he would offer to meet them
understand they wanted to sell it that
way let's take the baseball ones last
time you shot a skyhook she's like I
can't remember within the well while I
was coaching you know working with
Andrew Bynum but I had to demonstrate
stuff so I got back in some kind of
shape at that point that's long far away
do you care about any of these lists
Kareem where ESPN had the greatest
college basketball player of all time
poll and I rail because you weren't
that you're the greatest college
basketball player of all time I was mad
I was probably madder than you would
ever be I'm guessing but Jordan was the
greatest college basketball player of
all time
just help me here if you don't care
about it then I won't care about it I
you know it's not important to me
because the people that would vote for
Michael Jordan I don't have the
perspective they didn't see me play I
wish they had seen Oscar play they
really changed their mind about that
Michael wasn't anywhere near the college
player that Oscar was so you know it's
it's all depends on your perspective and
to understand that you can see where
someone would say that because you know
Michael style was so charismatic you
know people think that that doesn't you
know what style and effect are two
different things but we look at Michael
amigo away he won six titles he didn't
lose Bill Russell won 11 he didn't lose
like I I know how do you decide you
can't and people who didn't see Bill
Russell play had no idea you know he's
he's stifled the whole league for 11
World Championships Michael Jordan had
six you know it's it's there's no
comparison but the people don't
understand what's being compared so
that's why they get involved you just
missed out on Russell did yeah my first
year in the league was his first year in
retire but I saw you against wilt and
that was supposed to be this big
showdown
oh let's see how you know Lew Alcindor
was gonna do against the great Wilt
Chamberlain what do you remember about
that first meeting yeah and that's
another thing that will like we don't
he's justit istel anomaly you know he's
not included in the greatest player of
all time it feels like because we go wow
that's wilt and
you know the NBA was different back then
yam was different but still what wilted
who's going to score 100 points average
what did the others do fifty point four
point yeah it's it's ridiculous what
wilted and nobody that saw him gets to
vote now they're you know they've all
passed on votes this past off so you
know I think he could've have to like
stop it in Arabs and then maybe people
will get it correct in how they assess
these things yeah and I tried I don't
want to be that guy who says get off my
lawn but it feels like I'm speaking up
for guys who people missed out on
because I I got to see everybody but
Bill Russell play you know I was there
in Cincinnati for Cincinnati Gardens
since I royalty I got to see those and
on Maravich when he came in when you
came in I mean run down the list of
these great players and I just say you
have no I
Oscar played with the Royals they were
horrible and then he got to Milwaukee
and then people go oh okay Oscar you won
a title they just they I don't know we
pick and choose on what is great now and
we to be tended I had somebody arguing
with me the other day about Rick Berry's
greatness and he said you had to see him
play like Rick Barry with that Golden
State warrior team that was not a good
team but it was a team and Rick Barry
was awesome back then but died somebody
say well draymond Green is better than
Rick Barry and I go exactly I said that
I've reacted the same way curry yeah no
idea what guys did so you know it's you
just talking to people who can't relate
to what happened before them yeah and I
know there's always this competitiveness
and and yours was probably hidden a
little bit more but I have to believe
there's every part of you that says your
is impact for better than anybody else
who's ever played the game I think so
but if you got time to argue
oh I'll continue to argue on your behalf
I actually saw the first time you played
Bill Walton in a preseason game at the
University of Dayton okay and I remember
because I loved bill I thought bill was
as true of team centers I'd ever seen
like understanding the game and and I
was like he had his long hair in the
bandana and I remember it didn't it
didn't go hook it didn't go that well
for Bill that that maybe it was like
when you you faced Chamberlain but Bill
got roughed up a little bit there you
ever talked to him about your your
meetings your head to heads no I wasn't
trying to embarrass what I could do my
team yeah but he has such praise for you
and rightfully so but yeah although I
think he dunked on you that one time in
the playoffs and when they when they won
the title and bill bill likes to bring
that up well that's one per bill and I
had a few so uh how are you feeling by
the way with the crime I'm involved in a
new technology now that enables me to
send messages to people and do
celebrations for them it's working
pretty good if you want know anything
about it go to iconic Graham calmly you
can see what what's keeping me up at
nights in and then it's spelled ICO and
oh my no I see Owen Oh grea Oh so I got
a Icona me calm as well here it is
yeah okay okay want to make sure I got
that right for messages you want me to
do a message for you celebration
weddings
birthdays graduations I can do all the
way now there any there's no hardware in
the background there if I walk into the
house do I know what you do for a living
or did for a living
no no Hardware no no jerseys okay I have
all my baseball stuff and all the stuff
that's important to me like will you may
sign the uniform you probably have more
baseball memorabilia than basketball
memorabilia is that correct yeah what's
your prized possession aside from the
Willie Mays autographed jerseys my
prized possession is in 1955 World
Series of baseball that what that has
phony signatures on it it has a couple
of phony signatures costs to the club
attendant used to you know sign
signatures of the guys who wouldn't sign
the baseball like so it's great to see
you and we appreciate your time as
always and keep writing
we appreciate it cream thank you very
much dad nice talking to you have a
great day and stay healthy
thank you that's a cream abdul-jabbar